&gt;&gt; We know the slope can be calculated by the difference in the y values,
divided by the difference of the x values. The rise divided by the run. I'm
going to label this point x2, y2 and this point x1, y1. So, y2 is 0 and y1 is 2.
Then x2 is 3 and x1 is 0. Notice again that I'm always using parenthesis when I
substitute in numbers. This is so I don't make a mistake with negative signs.
When I carry out the subtraction, I get negative two thirds. Negative two thirds
was the slope. But wouldn't it be easier if we could just read it from the
equation? It's not as easy to read off the slope from an equation written in
standard form, as it was with an equation written in slope-intercept form. But
you can still find the slope.